this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill earlier this month the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change released a chilling report a
report that has taken three years of
research and another week of discussions
between governments and its riders to
finalize informing the world that we are
nowhere near on track to minimize the
effects of global warming to just 1.5
degrees and instead we are now on track
to exceed 3 degrees Celsius above
pre-industrial levels by the end of the
century going above this 1.5 degree
change is going to cause serious damage
to the livability of this planet going
to three degrees may just open Pandora's
Box increasing the likelihood of heat
waves droughts floods and just making
life more difficult for us and the
plants and animals that shared the world
with us in order to avoid that outcome
the IPCC laid out five steps we need to
achieve one global emissions of co2 need
to decline by 45 percent by 2030 to
renewables need to provide 85 percent of
global electricity by 2050 three Coley's
must reduce to practically zero for 7
million square kilometers of land will
be needed for energy crops and five we
must reach a net of zero emissions by
2050 these are incredibly ambitious
targets that let's face it we probably
won't achieve without a massive shift in
global attitudes we are on a collision
course with disaster and we've no
captain's steering the ship so do we
have any last-minute solutions to save
us from catastrophe solar radiation
management has been touted as our best
option for rapidly lowering the planet's
temperature solar radiation management
is a long term for something The
Simpsons thought of in 1995 simply block
out the Sun to reduce the energy we
receive here on the surface of the
planet and therefore reduce the
temperature there has been several
methods proposed to achieve this some
more realistic than others the most
sci-fi of all the solutions proposes
that we place some form of Sun Shade in
space like the one proposed by Gregory
Benford he recognized the potential of
Lagrange point one an area between the
Earth and the Sun where the
gravitational forces between the
and the earth allow an object in the
position to remain in that position here
a sunshade would provide a constant
reduction in solar radiation but placing
a solid sunshade that would cause a
massive shadow roving over the Earth's
surface every day is obviously not a
reasonable solution instead Benford
proposed using a concave Fresnel lens
which would not completely block out the
Sun but defuse it slice the Fresnel lens
is a compact lens designed to minimize
the weight and bulk of the material
required to make it it takes advantage
of the fact that light is only deflected
as the passes between the boundary of
mediums therefore the thickness of lens
material really doesn't matter only its
geometry so a traditional lens can be
drastically reduced in weight like so he
estimated that a lens with a 1000
kilometer diameter could reduce the
solar energy reaching earth by 0.5 to 1%
at an initial cost of about 10 billion
dollars a far cry from the prices
required for our previously discussed
method of carbon capture through a
forestation of the Sahara for
considering the James Webb telescope an
object vastly smaller than this lens
itself cost 10 billion dollars I would
say Ben for its calculations are more
science fiction than science fact on top
of this Lagrange point one is a point of
unstable equilibrium small disturbances
in the Earth's gravitational field can
dislodge the object from its position
and so it would need some way of
correcting its position frequently I
personally don't see this as a viable
solution and it has not been seriously
considered by any governing body this
can't be said for stratospheric aerosol
injection this method seeks to recreate
the global cooling effects the world
experiences during massive volcanic
eruptions like those of 1991 when Mount
Pinatubo erupted the largest
stratospheric disturbance in a century
in a time when we had the tools to
measure its impact this eruption not
only blew 500 feet of the mountains peak
off it also injected an estimated 15
million tons of sulfur dioxide into the
stratosphere where reacted with the
water vapor to form sulfuric acid
atmospheric physics is definitely not my
area of expertise so I asked my friend
Simon Clark who has a PhD in the subject
to explain the
uric acid which formed in the atmosphere
in the aftermath the Pinatubo eruption
had a substantial effect on global
climates in the 15 months following the
eruption the global average surface
temperature decreased by no point six
degrees Celsius and this happened for
two reasons firstly the small droplets
of sulfuric acid which formed in the
atmosphere after the eruption reflected
short wavelengths of radiation now the
Sun mostly emits short wavelengths of
radiation so the sulfuric acid reduced
the amount of radiative energy from the
Sun which reached the surface of the
earth thanks to the first law of
thermodynamics with the same amount of
energy being thermally radiated out to
space by the earth but less energy
coming in from the Sun the Earth's
global average temperature decreased
note by the way that this is different
from the radiative effects of greenhouse
gases like carbon dioxide and methane
which interact with comparatively long
wavelengths of radiation long wavelength
radiation is what the earth thermally
radiates to space so by injecting
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
we're doing the opposite of what
happened in the aftermath of the
Pinatubo eruption with limiting the
amounts of energy that the earth
thermally radiates to space but the
amount of energy that's coming in from
the Sun is relatively constant so the
opposite effect happens and the global
average temperature increases the second
reason why the sulfuric acid from the
eruptions substantially changed the
climate is because it was injected into
the stratosphere the stratosphere is the
layer of the atmosphere above the layer
we live in the troposphere and extends
from about ten kilometers to about 50
kilometers above the surface and it has
very different dynamics to what we're
used to seeing in the atmosphere in
particular there's almost no vertical
motion and almost no precipitation so if
you put something up there it stays up
there for a really long time so the
sulfuric acid had the time to
radiatively affect the climate sticking
around for much longer than if it had
just been injected into the lower
atmosphere where it would have been
rained out in a couple of weeks so we
know it works the next part is figuring
out how to implement it on a massive
scale sulfur is a relatively cheap
material but getting it into the
stratosphere it could be expensive some
have proposed balloons that will carry
the materials into the
stratosphere and explode these are a
relatively low-cost solution for single
low payload trips like weather data
collection or sending random [ __ ] really
high in the sky with the GoPro for
America ting campaign but for something
like this where we will need to send
millions of tons of material it's not a
clever option others who have obviously
not considered not only the cost
engineering impossibility and energy
required to pump the materials to that
height have proposed giant towers
ultimately the easiest method will be
the tried and true method of hauling
tons of liquid to the stratosphere
with a refueling plane like the kc-10
which will be able to run multiple
missions a day and carry a hundred and
sixty tons with each flight this is a
realistic solution that humans could
employ quickly in dire straits but at
what cost to our planet once we start
this program we cannot stop until we
reduce our concentration of greenhouse
gases in our atmosphere which itself
will take years if not decades of
disciplined work around the world we
will need multiple of these aircrafts
spraying millions of tons of pollutants
into our atmosphere to counteract the
other pollutants we have released if we
stopped without fixing the underlying
issue
first we will undergo rapid climate
change to pre injection levels in just a
couple of years a shock change like this
would give ecosystems little time to
adapt and would likely result in a
massive die-off it would be like placing
a bandage on a wound as it continues to
fester under the surface on-scene
climate scientists are confident that
global temperatures will stabilize if
the correct concentration is reached we
have historic data from volcanic
eruptions to show the method works and
we have decent models to calculate how
quickly the aerosols will leave the
stratosphere and so how often we would
need to fly additional missions but what
we do know is vastly overshadowed by
what we don't know even our most
powerful computer models cannot predict
how this method will affect individual
countries we are still struggling to
understand how our world is changing
with a relatively simple variable like
carbon dioxide concentration trying to
predict how the planet will react if we
force it in the other direction is even
more complicated
how will plants and microbial life be
affected by the decrease in direct
sunlight
how will the water cycle change
rate the Amazon rainforest will inject
water into the atmosphere through
transpiration will likely fall how will
this modify local and global circulation
patterns some regions will undergo rapid
climate change with changes in
precipitation and temperatures in ways
we cannot predict what impact will that
have on political relations when some
countries benefit and others suffer as a
consequence of our geoengineering
ultimately the biggest problem this
method faces is bureaucracy who controls
the organization of a massive operation
like this that will have a worldwide
impact does one country like the United
States take it upon themselves to alter
the climate when their economy starts to
suffer or will the UN come to an
agreement on a target concentration the
technology is cheap enough that a single
person with deep enough pockets could
take it upon themselves to finance it
putting the fate of billions into the
palm of their hat in a sense this is an
analogous for the problem we are already
facing while small island nations are
screaming for change as they literally
sink into the ocean while other regions
suffer the worst droughts in decades but
for most acting on climate change is not
in their interest their commercial
inertia just keeps some steam rolling
along not noticing the insignificant
minorities in their path if we could
manage to create a single global
Authority with the power to act on
climate change decisively we would
already be in better shape to minimize
the impacts of climate change to make
these changes we need committed
leadership we need more people to care
about this issue and take action I'm
trying to use my platform here to
encourage you to be that change and
hopefully you can go out and do the same
to use your voice to inspire action to
help you along with that goal you could
take this course on Skillshare from
acclaimed TEDx speaker simon Sinek that
teaches you the skills you need to
present your ideas in a way that will
inspire action this is just one in over
20,000 classes you could take on
Skillshare that range from creative
skills like painting and music lessons
to technical skills on coding with
professional and understandable classes
that follow a clear learning curve you
can dive in and start learning how to do
the work you love a premium membership
begins around $10 a month for unlimited
access to all courses but the first
1,000 people are sign up with this link
we'll get there first two months for
free so ask yourself right now what
skill have you been putting off learning
while project have you been dreaming of
completing but you aren't sure if you
have the skills to do it why not start
right now and sign up to skill share
using the link below to get your first
two months free you've nothing to lose
and a valuable life skill to gain as
usual thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links to my
Twitter Facebook discord server
subreddit and Instagram pages are below
[Music]
[Music]